google wants to hack our election google
could well
elect the next president they have a
monopoly on information on what you know
and what i know fight against this
threat to our democracy
as the 2020 presidential election heats
up
alarmism over big tech's influence on
voters is once again reaching a fever
pitch
democrats fear the impact of so-called
fake news and russian bots
while republicans complain of supposed
anti-conservative bias
and censorship on platforms like google
twitter and facebook
they all agree on one thing the federal
government needs more power over online
speech
we will hold social media platforms
accountable
russia was running all those bots about
me they treat conservatives and
republicans very unfairly it's not right
it's not fair it may not be legal
republicans have put a spotlight on the
claims of one noted researcher and
self-proclaimed proud clinton supporter
to bolster their allegations of liberal
activism by tech companies
psychologist robert epstein dr robert
epstein a harvard trained
psychologist dr epstein i found your
testimony
incredibly powerful and incredibly
concerning dr robert epstein
produced a series of studies that he
claims show that search engines and
social media companies manipulate their
users to help democrats
a former editor-in-chief of psychology
today epstein has called google's search
engine the most powerful mind control
device
ever devised in 2016 google search
algorithm
likely impacted undecided voters in a
way that shifted
at least 2.6 million votes to hillary
clinton
whom i supported if any head headline
comes out of this hearing
that should be it while google has
called his work
nothing more than a poorly constructed
conspiracy theory donald trump cited
epstein's research to explain why he
lost the popular vote by nearly
3 million votes prompting hillary
clinton to call the work debunked
last year epstein was invited to testify
before congress by texas senator ted
cruz to warn of the existential threat
that big tech poses to democracy
as originally conceived cannot survive
big tech as currently empowered in 2020
you can bet that all of these companies
are going to go
all out they will have the power to
shift
15 million votes he's been sounding the
alarm about what he alleges could be
even more pervasive interference
in favor of democrats in the current
election you have hard
evidence that google is sensory and you
can back that up
oh absolutely so i explained this i told
this to congress the study that i
referred to was irrefutable and no one
has been able to
disprove him but a careful review of
epstein's work reveals that though he
has conducted scientifically sound
experiments his findings don't fully
support the claims that he's been making
about the influence of tech giants on
real world elections
election by election i can actually
calculate how many votes
these companies can shift a big part of
that is what you call the search engine
manipulation effect or seam
so can you just briefly talk about what
that is and how you arrived at your
conclusions
fifty percent of all clicks go to the
top two search items
uh ninety-five percent of all clicks go
on that first page of search results
so i asked a simple question which is if
people
trust those high-ranking search results
that much
could i use them in an experiment to
shift people's opinions about candidates
perhaps
maybe even shift how they would vote
i predicted i could probably shift
people one way or the other by two or
three percent
that was my guess first experiment i ran
the i got a shift of 48 which i didn't
believe
uh i redid the experiment with a new
group
i got a shift of 63 percent which is a
which is enormous it's one of the
largest behavioral effects i think ever
discovered
in epstein's initial lab-based and
online experiments
participants spent up to 15 minutes
researching details in a foreign
election they knew nothing about
they used a fake search engine similar
to google that reordered results to
favor a particular candidate
then epstein asked them how much their
opinions of the candidate had shifted
he called the effect he was measuring
the search engine manipulation effect
or seem biased search results can easily
produce
shifts in the opinions and voting
preferences of undecided voters
by up to 80 percent in some
demographic groups i think when a lot of
people hear things like you can shift 80
of people to a different candidate that
seems on its face kind of
ridiculous right so you observe this in
the laboratory and then you're saying
that we'll see that same shift in the
real world and what gives you confidence
that that's the case
i want to be very very clear on one
issue here
i i'm my big i'm my biggest skeptic
so when i get a huge number uh
you know in an experiment showing a lot
of people's opinions just shifted
uh believe me i i'm very very very
skeptical
that's why i repeat experiments over and
over and over again i do them in
different ways
they are they're unbelievable numbers
but they're real
that's the problem uh what i'm asking
about is
what applicability that really has to a
real world election in which you have
millions of other variables that you're
not measuring that could be confounding
it
um and you have people that are
bombarded by all sorts of news sources
that don't just rely on
search ranking to decide their political
preferences in one of those
experiments in india those were
actually real voters right in the middle
of the voting period because voting
goes on for three weeks in india these
are people being bombarded as you said
bombarded by all kinds of uh of
sources of influence but we got
an enormous shift with these real
voters we had in some demographic groups
shifts of
60 or more that's a very significant
result as far as i'm concerned in how
easy it is to change
what people say uh how it changes
whether or not
they vote i think that's a totally
different question i asked aaron brown
a statistician and former chief risk
manager at the hedge fund aqr capital
management to take a look at epstein's
research
he says that in experiments of this sort
it's not hard to manipulate what
participants say
and that epstein is over extrapolating
from his results
when epstein ran his online experiment
in india in 2014 on real voters
he exposed them to biased search engine
results for an average of 5 minutes
and then asked them how much their
opinions had shifted whether that
translates to
actual changes in the vote people
ultimately cast
i think there's zero evidence for that
brown says that participants in this
type of behavioral research
often answer in the way they think the
experimenter wants them to
and even if their opinions really do
change by the time they show up at an
actual polling site it's likely that all
sorts of other factors have changed
their opinions yet again
the people whose votes you're gonna
shift with something as trivial as five
minutes on a
by a search engine are going to be the
people whose votes are easiest to shift
they're probably going to be in people
who aren't voting for one thing
so these people are going to ship back
and forth a hundred times before
election day if they ever
uh get to the polls uh at all and so
when he says that he got 60
shifts among some demographics in that
study do you think that that's a
meaningful
result that we can sort of map on to uh
real elections
not at all you can't assume that that's
the only thing changing people's votes i
mean that's an absurd assumption
their algorithm all by itself it is
already determining the outcomes of
close elections around the world
all by itself epstein has used the
findings from his search engine
manipulation effects studies to make
bold claims about real election results
for example he asserts that as of 2015
bias in google search alone has been
changing upwards of 25
of the outcomes of national elections
worldwide can you just explain how you
arrived at those numbers from the
experiments that you just talked about
that's actually pretty simple we simply
looked at the margins by which national
elections around the world
were being won and it turns out in
national elections especially
the win margin is often extremely
extremely small
and then we looked at again the same
research which tells us what proportion
of uh of undecided voters can be shifted
in any given election uh and just kind
of put the two together and that's where
we
came up with this estimate of upwards of
25
of the national elections in the world
as of 2015 we're being decided by
a google search engine the logic he just
described is
just wrong there's lots of other things
that influence people's notes
how many people change their vote
because of what their spouse thinks what
their friend thinks
an ad they saw a book they read a movie
they saw
um an experience they had what you would
have to show to show that they were
actually influencing elections is you
need a controlled experiment you need
actually to see how many
actual votes shifted not how many people
reported a shift in opinion
as evidence that tech companies can
affect voting behavior
epstein points to a study run on 61
million facebook users on election day
in 2010 that tested
the impact of get out the vote messages
they actually measured how many more
people got off their sofas and went and
voted
so they sent it to 60 million people
that caused an additional
340 000 more people to go vote but brown
says this fits epstein's pattern of
emphasizing seemingly large numbers
without giving their proper context
the facebook study found that only one
out of five people who said they voted
after seeing the get out the vote
message
actually did and the most effective
message tested increased real voting by
just point four percent
it makes epstein's higher estimates of
his effect seem
implausible so of of whatever percentage
you know fifteen percent or something
who said they changed their mind in this
experiment
maybe only three percent of them voted
and maybe you know
only point three percent of them
actually change their vote on the basis
we just have no idea but it's gonna be
much smaller it's gonna be much smaller
than the effect he observed
that's a very far cry from the numbers
that you're talking about right so why
do you think that when we look at this
60 million person study that's happening
is it the actual turnout to vote
that's so much different or what's your
take on that actually
what that means is that if on election
day
in 2016 uh mark zuckerberg
had decided to send out a go vote
reminder
just to democrats number one
no one would have known and that would
have given
two democrats that day at least
450 000 additional votes
if you can shift 15 million votes you
can i mean
you could create a 20 win margin in
response to brown's
criticisms epstein reiterated in an
email to reason that his estimate that
tech companies could shift 15 million
votes this year is quote conservative
based on what i know we can do in our
experiments though his studies measured
shifts in opinion
and not voting behavior directly epstein
says that research on polling suggests
that people's stated intentions are
excellent predictors of their votes
because facebook had a way of at least
estimating who actually voted
it's a much more stronger result that's
when we we can have a lot more phases
it's not a theoretical
thing based on a sort of chain of logic
after his seam experiments epstein had
to answer one more
critical question before he could arrive
at the number of real votes google was
changing
is the company actually biasing the
information it shows to users
the google whistleblower has come out of
the shadows
epstein says the answer is yes pointing
to leaked documents
published by the conservative activist
group project veritas and interviews
with ex-employees that allege google
sometimes does intervene to re-rank
search results
or remove content it deems objectionable
we're pushing down the fake news we're
demoting it
and we are increasing the authoritative
news and promoting it
i felt that our entire election system
was going to be
compromised forever these companies are
absolutely determined
to control the outcome of the upcoming
election
the term re-ranking is used in the
documents
they use blacklists to either remove
content or demote it there's a lot of
material on what they call
within google algorithmic fairness
algorithmic fairness so a simple example
would be most ceos in the us are men
back white men now if you type ceo into
google and you're looking at images
you're going to get a mix you're going
to get some more minorities some more
women thrown in
whether that's representative or not
you see they've they have ways of
balancing from their perspective
balancing content
any way they want to balance it just
like
i do in my experiments tech platforms
have often been inconsistent in
explaining how they apply their
community guidelines to remove or limit
certain content but experts in online
search
argue the technology is necessarily
complex and always evolving and several
studies have concluded that there's no
clear evidence google biases results for
political purposes
company executives also deny ever doing
so a dr epstein's study we have
investigated we don't agree with the
methodology
epstein needed proof they were doing
just that so in 2016 he ran a study in
which he secretly monitored the search
results of 95 field agents in 24 states
after they typed neutral terms such as
hillary's health plan
into google bing and yahoo we had the
searches so we could see
whether they were biased in any way we
found
a pro-hillary clinton bias
and i was a very strong hillary clinton
supporter in
all 10 search positions on the first
page of google
search results but not on bing
or yahoo that's extremely important the
fact that it's
we're seeing that bias on google but not
the other search engines
that says that again for whatever reason
their
algorithms are actually favoring
hillary clinton after measuring the bias
epstein combined these results with the
shifts in opinion he was able to
generate in his earlier seam research to
calculate how many votes google had
supposedly shifted in real national
elections
if there is any kind of favoritism in
search results
we know from the same research without
any doubt that that will in a big
election
shift millions of votes in the weeks
leading up to the 2018 election
bias in google's search results may have
shifted
upwards of 78.2
million votes spread across many races
what we're seeing here is actual rigging
i mean yeah this is not paranoia this
this is
fact this is rock solid fact
but epstein wasn't able to determine the
source of the bias in his field agent
search results
and his monitoring work has been
criticized by other social scientists in
part for using a small number of
participants who are unlikely to be
representative of the u.s electorate
it's shifting the people who are
vulnerable who are undecided
and the shifts are simply enormous
and though his claims focus on undecided
voters his data on the bias they're
exposed to is especially limited
of his 95 field agents in 2016 only 21
identified themselves as undecided
and he didn't determine the political
preferences of others isn't that a
confounding variable if you don't know
what the political preferences of people
are because like you're saying you know
one of the big differences between your
study and what google actually does is
that google has
basically a dossier on every person that
has all these behaviors
and they customize search results and
things to the individual so
isn't it possible that the people in
your group they were seeing
biased search based on their own
pre-existing political preferences
we would have ways of detecting that for
example
uh if that if that were true
then we'd expect to see uh you know
a pro democrat results uh in
blue states uh and pro-republican
results
in red states if we're seeing
pro-democrat results in both blue and
red states
but so you had 95 people right so you
couldn't have had more than like
two or three people right in any given
state
again i need to emphasize that uh
these systems i've set up so far are
proof-of-concept
uh projects uh
you know in 2020
i think there's more at stake here and i
think
that we want to we want to have numbers
uh that aren't just statistically
valid we want to have numbers that are
psychologically valid
and that means having a much much
larger number of field agents what we
need
are data literally millions of pieces of
data coming in
every day from a very diverse group of
people
whose demographics we know why are you
comfortable
uh giving these number estimates now why
not just say
this is a significant effect we don't
know what effect it will have in the
real world we think it'll shift it this
way and we're gonna wait to see
why do you give these you know these
these numbers where you're extrapolating
directly from your data to the real
world
i'm very careful uh when i make
extrapolations uh
i'm very careful to word things uh in a
way that
you know i think has integrity so what i
said in 2016
was that if the level of bias
that we found in the sample we collected
if that level of bias had been present
nationwide
that would have shifted somewhere
between 2.6 and 10.4 million votes to
hillary clinton
uh and you know i stand by that i i've
never
said i know that level of bias was
present nation i've never said that
you testified before this committee that
google's manipulation of votes
gave at least 2.6 million
additional votes to hillary clinton in
the year 2016.
is that correct i must correct you the
2.6 million is a
rock bottom minimum the range is between
2.6
and 10.4 million depending on how
aggressively they used the techniques
that i've been studying now for six and
a half years
i you know again i'm very careful and
in the way i word things because i'm
very very skeptical
uh about my own work i think that's
why my work is is you know pretty solid
his results are
pretty solid and they're very scientific
yaki overstates them but mostly what he
does is present them artfully
aaron brown says the issue is not
epstein's experimental design
but the fact that he continues to repeat
numbers that would only be accurate if
the effects he's measured were the soul
factors influencing voters
and in the context of all the things
that influenced votes he has not
convinced me
that this is a significant one but
epstein writes that brown has no idea
how powerful new forms of influence can
be
especially influence that people can't
see seem is an especially dangerous form
of influence because it is in effect
subliminal the political campaigns i
mean they're
they're doing all kinds of shenanigans
on these platforms and
they're buying ads and you know so
doesn't that make a difference and the
answer is no
that makes no difference all of that is
competitive which is healthy that's a
good thing but if the platform
itself favors
one candidate or party you cannot
counteract that by any means unlike
other forms of attempted online voter
manipulation like political ads biased
news stories and even russian troll
farms
epstein argues that tech companies
influence is more insidious
since users assume computer generated
content is neutral
and they can be manipulated repeatedly
over long periods of time without
knowing it
google can take a 50 50 split among
undecided voters
and change it into a 90 10 split with
no one knowing that they have been
manipulated i mean my jaw's open
but brown says the world is full of
implicit messaging and unlike in
epstein's
research studies have shown directly
that other types of unconscious
influence
can have a large effect on real voting
behavior you know the top person on the
ballot gets somewhere between one and
ten percent
more votes than they would get if you
reverse the ballot order there's plenty
of
uh subliminal and and you know implicit
uh messages people get all the time
you don't need an international
conspiracy or a secret group of
uh technocrats in silicon valley to uh
influence elections if anyone draws news
out of this hearing i would encourage
you to review very carefully dr
epstein's testimony
epstein's work is once again gaining
traction this election cycle
as politicians seek greater control over
activity online
we as a country cannot tolerate
political censorship blacklisting
and rigged search results my executive
order calls for new regulations
under section 230 of the communications
decency act
president trump recently signed an
executive order targeting social media
and tasked the fcc with investigating
tech
platforms for violations of section 230
otherwise known as the internet's first
amendment
i think this hearing has underscored the
need for congress to revisit that
nobody wants to see a federal speech
police deciding what is and
isn't permissible the goal here kim is
not to get less speech the goal is to
get more speech
republicans in congress have proposed
legislation that would largely eliminate
the speech protections in section 230
allowing the government to punish tech
companies if officials were to deem a
user's post unacceptable
and the department of justice is
reportedly planning to file a new
anti-trust case against google before
the election
and the step on the line beyond that is
a teddy roosevelt step and it's not just
republicans agitating for control over
online speech
they behave like monopolists they need
to be broken
apart senate democrats joined them in a
bipartisan effort to subpoena tech ceos
in advance of the election and numerous
prominent democrats
including joe biden and kamala harris
have promised further crackdowns on
internet platforms for the content users
post
section 230 should be revoked
immediately should be revoked number one
for zuckerberg and other platforms
that's a pretty foundational law of the
modern
nature-based internet exactly right and
it should
be revoked it should be revoked
you've also said that there needs to be
strict regulation of
of companies like google what's your
case for that yes i used to call for
strict regulation i've stopped doing
that because with google there is
actually a simple solution
uh to the threats that that particular
company poses
and that is to make their index which is
the database they use to generate search
results
to make the index into a public commons
so google's dominance would disappear
they could still make lots of money
you know big customers would have to pay
maybe to access their index
but the point is that's a simple
solution that's very very light touch
regulation you know there are things we
can do
the eu has been extremely aggressive if
the federal government does ever step
in to regulate you're not going to like
it embattled facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg is calling for stricter
regulation of the web including
his own company the irony is that some
big tech ceos actually welcome
regulation
because they already have teams of
attorneys and lobbyists at their
disposal but new legal requirements are
costly barriers to entry for upstart
competitors
i'm a big believer in the free market
but we have to admit when the free
market's not working
and it hasn't worked here and i think
it's inevitable that there will be some
level of
regulation so would you work with us in
terms of what regulations you think are
necessary in your industry
absolutely okay would you submit uh some
proposed regulations
yes we should be setting standards not
unlike the europeans doing it
relative to privacy a study done one
year after the eu passed sweeping
regulations in 2018 in the name of
protecting privacy
found that google and facebook had in
fact gained market share
it's a well thought out crafted piece of
legislation
i think the europeans have it right i
think that they
get things right recently we had mark
zuckerberg testifying before congress
begging them to regulate him and the
google ceo doing the same exact thing
which is what always happens with these
large companies they can afford the
compliance costs and it limits their
upstart competition so
you know why are you confident that
these regulations would not do what
they've done with other
telecommunications companies
well i'm very much afraid um that
the regulatory approach uh
will not work at all but partly because
the regulations actually get written by
the companies typically
you know breaking up google breaking up
facebook they won't remove
these threats in fact they'll really
just enrich
the major stockholders but you know
there's a much larger issue here which
is
how could law and regulation possibly
keep up with
technology that's impossible technology
moves so
rapidly that i just don't think laws and
regulations are going to be able to
protect people
so how do you protect people long term
moving forward and the answer
is monitoring systems because monitoring
systems are tech
tech can keep up with tech
i'm raising funds now to build a much
more comprehensive comprehensive system
in 2020
one that will allow us to catch big tech
in the act
this is going to cost more than 50
million dollars yeah
epstein is convinced that the influence
he's measuring is just the tip of the
iceberg since tech companies have vast
troves of user-specific data to mine
and can use many other so-called
ephemeral effects through search
and video suggestions answer boxes news
feeds and more
to target and manipulate voters in the
real world on an ongoing basis
you know i haven't tried this but what
happens if we hit people with five
effects at the same time
heading into the 2020 vote epstein says
his only interest is in free and fair
elections but his alarmist predictions
have aided politicians opportunistic
efforts to get americans to hand them
more power over the internet
and to control the free exchange of
ideas online if any of our congress
people could look at these numbers they
would be stunned and they would take
action i guarantee it
well i hope that video of this
conversation goes everywhere
on facebook and google despite the
limitations of his research and
measuring the power of tech companies to
influence election outcomes
or whether they're actually trying to do
so epstein continues to speculate on the
number of votes they're shifting
confident that his claims haven't gone
nearly far enough
a lot of the social chaos that we see
that's all around us is actually
driven by the big tech companies you
know
out of chaos comes order right
it's going to be their order that's
coming
i think the problem is much bigger than
i've been saying it is and i've been
saying it's a big problem but i think
it's actually much bigger
so what that tells me is that the
numbers i've been getting over the years
which are high their big numbers are all
too small
you